[Applause]  president Trump has great courage he  faces down the fake media every day  but Congress needs to step up and have  equal courage to defend the president  Hunter Biden made $50,000 a month that's  the definition of corruption we know he  got it only because of his family  connections we also now know the name of  the whistleblower the whistleblower  needs to come before Congress as a  material witness because he worked for  Joe Biden at the same time hunter Biden  was getting money from corrupt oligarchs  I say tonight to the media do your job  and print his name  [Applause]  and I say this to my fellow colleagues  in Congress to every Republican in  Washington step up and subpoena hunter  Biden and subpoena the whistleblower  and I say to my colleagues if shifty  ship will not let hunter Biden come and  if you will not bring the whistleblower  for every Republican in Congress should  take a walk and say this is a farce  [Applause]